New York City where the stars are as
much a part of the city as the skyline
where dreams and illusion are
intertwined for Anika Ballman New York
is the cultural capital of the world she
came here from Germany just four weeks
ago it's a bold move but Annika's dream
is to make it on Broadway ideally with a
role in Phantom of the Opera yep mitzvah
you gave me two years and i'll be up
there she says it all started when I was
four yeah yeah we've come to New York to
find Germans who are living the American
dream what drives them what hurdles that
they have to overcome
Annika's mother took her to Phantom of
the Opera when she was 4 years old and
the budding singer fell in love with the
story of the choir girl who became an
opera star because she said Mr festered
as a co she says the story captivated
her when she first saw it the music the
whole production moved her she wanted to
be like Christine to be a singer now she
says she's closer to her goal swimming
under strict me a gun Anika wants to
make it big just like her favorite
musical protagonist but the 25 year old
will only be able to stay in New York
with a work visa and for that she'll
need a contract with a music producer
annika makes ends meet with occasional
performances in restaurants photos of
American stars have a special place in
many New York bars Anika has some
experience she had dozens of gigs back
in Germany after finishing her dance and
vocal performance degree here the
pressure is really on to look her best
no one looks at my feet she says I've
got a stain but there's no time for that
now looking good is part of the job and
eco can never be sure who will be in the
audience there might just be someone who
can give her her big break ready truck
right thank you a few encouraging words
from the pianist and then she gives it
her all even if the audience could be
bigger
I found a dream that I could speak to
we'll check back in with Anika in a
couple of weeks in the meantime we're
off to Brooklyn right next to Manhattan
it's a sort of big city within the big
city popular with many who can't afford
the astronomical rents in Manhattan one
of them is entrepreneur Bennett male
he's agreed to show us his company key
see it's the brainchild of Bernard male
and his former University buddies from
Munich their product turns normal cell
phones into digital house keys the keys
can also be sent by phone tells me that
their product lets people use cell
phones to open doors and that they can
send their keys electronically to
everyone who comes to visit
Bennett hopes his idea will help him
take over the American market that's why
he and his co-founders made the move to
New York earlier in the year for now
they're working out of this apartment
for a few weeks rent free the actual
tenant is a friend of Bernard who's out
of town at the moment they're living off
the 35 thousand dollars in prize money
that they won with their business idea
in my York saraswat Manhattan is a
business coach who helps young
entrepreneurs as part of a mentoring
program offered by the city government
designed to help fledgling companies cut
through red tape today Bernard is
showing the coach the latest changes
they've made to his acts firstly they
had a great business idea for New York
City they identified a problem which is
accessing buildings that is really a big
problem in New York City the second
thing is they had a great vision for
where they wanted to take the company on
some of the smiles Kesey may someday
help thousands of New Yorkers get into
their offices for now the company is
still looking for an affordable office
of its own
the next a 27 year old Bernard is off to
an important meeting he's going to
install one of key systems in a New York
office in Salinas local electrician
takes care of the technical aspects and
often done dozens Bennett says this is
the first of kisses devices to be
installed in New York and they hope
it'll work in the password of the
wireless yeah then it's but something
isn't quite right the key see device
doesn't seem to work sector that's what
we do that's the configuration right the
electrician can't find the problem a
setback with their very first customer
if they fail here the key sea cruise
American Dream might end before it even
begins Bennett says the device didn't
work as they had hoped now they'll have
to come back next week and install
another relay
it's up to the young inventor to do
damage control he tries to explain the
glitch to the customer button it didn't
I think it didn't accept it or it
couldn't read the password or whatever
I'll pay him another visit in a couple
of weeks to see if he has his product up
and running from exes iphone
first let's check in to see how our
singer Anika ballman is getting along
she's met with producers almost every
day played gigs and practiced her
networking skills but still no contract
to keep her spirits up Anika takes long
walks through her dream city she loves
the excitement that New York has brought
into her life the road to her Broadway
dream is long she says so she's ready to
make some compromises and fire me she
says until then she will definitely stay
in America and do something in the arts
it could be acting or singing in a
nightclub a cabaret or on Broadway as
long as she's on stage acting singing or
both of course she misses her friends
and family in Germany I ask her why
she's so determined to stay dimension D
mentalities she tells me it's the people
and their passion for music she says
she's not ready to give that up on her
walks through New York she meets people
who have seen their dreams fade away
almost 50 million people in the US are
dependent on food stamps
annika doesn't want to think about what
will happen if she doesn't realize her
dreams of becoming a Broadway star she's
determined to make a name for herself in
New York for her auditions she needs a
head shot rudolph von damela is here to
help her with that he's a new york-based
our photographer and a friend of her
mother he's worked with the likes of
heidi klum and kate moss I asked if she
enjoyed the shoot and of course she says
it's especially fun working with someone
who's so great at what they do and who
gives you good feedback also when you
notice that the person you are working
with is having fun to the photographer's
glad to help out young people even at
the beginning of their careers it's
always good to help of course if you can
and if you can help somebody doing
something good and fulfill their dreams
that's a beautiful thing because you
become part of their dreams Rudolph's
words give Annika encouragement to
pursue her dream of Broadway fame
Bennett mail is also confident when I
meet him again he's gotten the bugs
worked out of his app and even has his
first customers I asked him about his
plans it will of heaven for your blow I
want to stay here he says because if I
make it here then I can make it in
Germany to that doesn't really apply the
other way around on the dictaphone
New York in Bennett males eyes is the
hardest market in the world but he's not
ready to close the door on Germany he
might be able to bring Kesey back home
once the company's firmly established a
couple of days later I meet a nikka
Borman in an upscale restaurant she's
nervous today she's signing on with her
new manager hey big to sign the contract
excited I am his name is Robert bloom
she met him through a friend he's sure
she's got a real chance ready he started
planning her next performances finally
Anika signs the dotted line okay you
feel different yes not quite like a
marriage contract haha Annika is
relieved to have found a manager like
Robert bloom he's already helped a lot
of newcomers get their start on the
Broadway stage and he's well-connected
in the music scene now that we're signed
the first thing I have to do is we have
to get her a work visa and no one visa
that will allow her to officially work
and get paid first Annika will have to
return to Germany for a few months to
apply for a work permit as soon as it's
issued should be back in New York
chasing her American dream I like this
place beautiful place
I meet Ben arnel again at a New York
trade fair he and his team are
introducing the app to visitors he says
business is running smoothly the moments
was it cool we have 20 customers in
Manhattan and Brooklyn he tells me it's
great we're earning real money but we
need to expand in Manhattan and really
all of New York in the coming months to
keep the business afloat berkeley new
york phones in bush logname for Bernard
stereotypes mean good business he
benefits from the fact that Americans
consider Germans very trustworthy when
it comes to security matters by next
year he expects to be in the black
that's home on zynga box what not he
says that following his dream and moving
to New York was worth it of course it
was risky but everything worked out and
now he and his crew are a success it's
everything they could have hoped for the
US remains a place that fascinates
Bernard and many other Germans making
their American dream a reality takes
strong will hard work and a bit of luck
you